جئت إلى هنا العام الماضي من أجل كأس العرب
أه فقط لأشعر نوعًا ما إذا
كانت الدولة مستعدة لاستضافة
كأس العالم ويمكنني أن أخبرك أنه في
عام واحد كان التغيير فلكيًا
، اجتمعت البلاد معًا وشكلت
معًا  برنامج جيد جدًا وقام
بعمل ممتاز. الملاعب جيدة جدًا ،
كان السكان مضيافين
ودودين للغاية ، وهذا لا يقدر بثمن ، إنها
دولة صغيرة تضم 320 ألف شخص ،
لكنكم أنتم يا رفاق قمتوا بعمل رائع نعم
وصلت في 15
نوفمبر وقطر  مدهش لقد عرفت ذلك قبل أن
أكون هنا منذ عامين وهذا
جنون تمامًا ، هل أعجبك ذلك
حتى الآن ، إنه أحد أفضل التدريبات
التي تشعر بها في قطر من حيث
المشاعر وكل
ما أستمتع به كنت قلقًا  قبل
مجيئي لأنني أتيت إلى كاتان ولكني
انضممت إليها وكل من
اتصلت به كان مهذبًا للغاية طوال الوقت
ليس لدي أي شكاوى بشأنه بشكل
لا يصدق مذهل تمامًا
أنا فرنسي ولكني أعيش فيه
الكويت رائعة ، لذا أنت
تحب دول الجولف منذ
أسبوعين ، نحن من أكسفورد إنجلترا ، هل
تحبها جيدة جدًا ، إنها
آمنة جدًا ، نظيفة جدًا ، أناس ودودون للغاية ،
لم يكن من الممكن أن تكون بيني أفضل ، هذا هو
عالمي الخامس  الكأس ، لذا فهذه هي معركة
كأس العالم التي أتيت إلى هنا من أجل أن يكون
الناس لطيفين ، لذا فإن كل شيء هنا
رائع في بنية التسلل مدهش
واللعبة أيضًا رائعة جدًا
[تصفيق]